hey everybody Mr Kobe here so I'm going
to film myself doing this dialysis lab
activity in case you're absent this will
be your makeup lab so make sure you have
a copy of your lab handout and what this
is it looks like a flat piece of plastic
but it's not this is actually what is
called dialysis tube and it doesn't look
like it but it's actually a tube if you
get it wet and rub your fingers between
it you can actually inflate it and you
can see I tied a knot in the bottom and
I just add some added some water here to
show you that yeah it actually is a tube
now it may not look like it but dialysis
tube has incredibly small microscopic
pores and holes that certain molecules
can pass through and so that's going to
be the point of this lab activity is
we're going to test our understanding of
diffusion passive transport and
diffusion to try to figure out what
molecules might be able to pass through
the the pores the little holes here of
dialysis tubing
so what I need to do is I need to soak
this dialysis tubing
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take this bottle here of glucose I'm
going to measure five milliliters of
glucose I'll measure it with my
graduated cylinder here cylinder here
I'm going to add five milliliters of
glucose
and I'm going to add five milliliters of
starch so five and five ten milliliters
of starch and then what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to pour the I'm gonna pour
the glucose in the starch I'm going to
pour it into a new dialysis tube right
here so that's just water right there
I'm going to dump the water and then
what I'm going to do is I'm going to add
five milliliters of glucose and five
milliliters of starch I'm going to put
the camera down and do that right now
I'll be back in a moment
okay so what I did is I used the
graduated cylinder right there and I
measured five milliliters of glucose and
starch and here they are they're all
kind of it's kind of just mixed together
but this little white soupy mixture here
is five milliliters of glucose mixed
with five milliliters of starch so
there's a total of 10 milliliters inside
of this dialysis tubing and you can see
that it's knotted closed
all right and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take this
dialysis tubing and I'm going to just
soak it in this water here this cup of
water Here and Now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to add some iodine drops
drops of iodine iodine has kind of an
orange bronze color to it I'm going to
add like 30 drops or so of iodine into
this testing cup so here we go one two
three four
five
six
seven oops
eight yeah well it doesn't have to be an
exact 30 drops it's okay uh 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16.
17 up there was a big drop right there
oh well
um yeah that's probably good right there
it's okay if it's not exactly 30 you're
we're still going to get the desired
result so yeah I kind of stopped
counting but there you go so the iodine
is in the cup
mixed with water so the the cup is
filled with a mixture of iodine and
water
and the dialysis bag is a mixture of
glucose and starch now I'm going to let
it sit I'm going to let it sit for
probably a good 20 or 30 minutes so I'm
going to pause the video I'm going to
come back about 20 30 minutes later from
now
okay so actually while that's sitting
while the dialysis bag is sitting in the
cup of iodine water I want to do this I
want to do this test right here I want
to show you what happens when starch and
iodine come into contact with one
another so here's my bottle of starch
I'm going to shake it up really quick
and I'm going to Simply add a few drops
of starch into this little cavity here
this little well here
there you go all right so there's some
starch there uh it's kind of like a
milky white color right now
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
add just a couple drops of iodine into
that uh that starch solution
and you can see all it really took is
one drop and if I kind of Stir It Up a
little bit you can see it's almost like
a blackish color there's like a almost a
deep purple blackish color so when
starch
and iodine when starch and iodine mix
that color
results so starch an iodine when they
mix together they make up that color now
there's another test I want to do I want
to do a glucose test so here's my bottle
of glucose
shake it up really quick and I'm going
to add a few drops of glucose into this
little well right here this little hole
indentation here so just a few drops is
all I need
that's probably good right there
and over here
are a couple of glucose testing strips
now if I hold this up you can see that
the original color of the glucose test
strip is blue if I dip this into the
glucose dip it for a few seconds wash it
out swirl it around a moment take it out
it'll slowly start to turn colors and if
I compare it to here's the strip on the
right the strip on the right has never
been used
you can see it's only been a few seconds
and there's already a color change you
can see that it's a a green color the
one on the left is a green if it turns
green what that means is that there's a
small amount of glucose present
and eventually if I let it sit it might
actually turn to a brown color because I
did use a lot of glucose
in this dropper bottle right here and so
if it if there's a lot of glucose
present that testing pad will eventually
turn to a brown color and it might take
a minute so I'm not going to sit here
for the full minute but it'll go green
if there's a small amount of glucose
which you can see and it actually turned
a brown color if there's a large amount
of glucose these tests right here the
starch test
and the glucose test are going to be
really important later on so make sure
you remember what just happened here
okay so before I show you the results
here's kind of what you're trying to
figure out here's a drawing summarizing
what happened so here's the dialysis
tube remember the dialysis tube has a
little tiny microscopic holes in it now
you can't see them
you can't see them they're too small to
see with the naked eye but they're there
and because there's little tiny holes
can some of the molecules pass through
those holes that's what we're trying to
figure out does starch exit you know
there's starch inside the bag did it
actually diffuse out
does glucose exit you know there's
glucose inside the bag does glucose
diffuse out
and does Iodine enter you know you added
we added drops of iodine to the watery
solution does Iodine diffuse in
we should be able to answer these
questions
by making some observations so now I'm
going to go to the results I'm going to
show you some observations that should
allow you to answer not just these
questions right here but all of the
questions that are on your lab handout
as well
okay so here are the results I actually
had to move into my office here yeah
area because my classroom ended up
getting used for something but here let
me show you three observations
observation number one if I hold up the
dialysis pack you can see there's a
blackish color on the inside that color
was not there before that black color
inside the bag that wasn't it wasn't
like that before something happened that
observation that there is now that dark
color on the inside of the bag should
help you answer one of the three
questions that I just showed you on the
Whiteboard a moment ago I'm gonna just
go ahead and store that there before I
get rid of it
a second observation look at the iodine
water it's not changed
the color of the iodine water is still
that same orange bronze bronzish color
it's unchanged even though nothing
happened to the color of the iodine
water that is an observation so this is
a second observation right here the
second observation that the iodine water
is unchanged should help you answer one
of the three questions on the Whiteboard
and then
here's another observation this is a
glucose testing strip if I swish it
around a few times
take it out
and give it a few seconds
now that's the one I just used right
there
it's a little blurry it looks like on my
camera
okay now here's a new one
so the one on the left has never been
used
but the one on the right has been used
you can see it's starting
to turn a more greenish color the one on
the left is fresh the one on the left
has never been used
but the one on the right it's subtle is
a little greenish color change if I wait
a little bit longer it might become a
little more noticeable
but the fact that it's changing colors
it's slowly changing colors that that
tells me something
so when I used the glucose strip and I
swooshed the glucose strip into the
iodine solution
you can see it's a little more Vivid now
again the one on the left has never been
used
the one on the right
was what I just used so there's a third
observation
again observation number one is that the
color inside of the dialysis pack has
appeared
observation number two is that the
iodine water has remained the same
and observation number three is that
this testing strip has turned colors
those three observations right there
should help you answer the rest of the
analysis questions good luck and I'll
see you in class